estos fueron dos de mis libros favoritos
de cuando era pequeño una colección de
cómo hacer códigos secretos como
descifrar mensajes un poco más adelante
los tres investigadores un grupo de
jóvenes que se dedicaban a descubrir
misterios y muchas de esas misterios
requerían también descifrar mensajes me
pegaba horas leyendo estos libros
un poco más adelante cayó en mis manos
este libro contacto de carl sagan
un grupo de astrónomos detectan un
mensaje alienígena
y a pesar de la importancia del
descubrimiento el mensaje en sí que es
una secuencia de números primos no
parece ser otra cosa que una forma
sofisticada de decirnos hola
hasta que los astrónomos descubren un
segundo mensaje y luego un tercer
mensaje escondidos en la polarización de
la luz
y no voy a revelar nada más sobre el
libro pero sí que os diré la fascinación
que me produjo esta idea la luz
transmitiendo un mensaje dentro de otro
mensaje
como hacían los alienígenas para
transmitir un mensaje en la polarización
de la luz como sabemos la luz es una
onda si viajando un plano vertical tiene
polarización vertical si viaja en un
plano horizontal tiene polarización
horizontal
pero además puede tener polarización
circular según si está girando en
sentido horario antihorario mientras
avanza y esto es lo que usaron los
alienígenas para su código en la
polarización
11 si la luz giraba en sentido horario y
un 0 si giraba en sentido antihorario
y esta secuencia de unos y ceros
escondida en la polarización de la luz
es el mensaje definitivo de la novela de
contacto
por supuesto codificar la luz para
transmitir mensajes no es patrimonio
exclusivo de mentes alienígenas nosotros
lo hacemos todos los días por ejemplo
con los semáforos los semáforos
codifican la longitud de onda el color
para decirnos si debemos parar o
continuar
o como sabemos podemos crear secuencias
temporales de luz para transmitir
mensajes
bien no vengo aquí a hablar hoy de
mensajes alienígenas sino de cómo
codificar la luz y aplicarlo en
fotografía
pero nuestro objetivo no va a ser
únicamente crear mejores fotografías
nuestro objetivo a ir un poco más allá
vamos a intentar ser capaces de ver lo
invisible
aquí tenemos una cámara de 1934 cómo
funcionaba la cámara de aquel entonces
teníamos una lente que enfoca rayos
sobre un sensor químico que produce la
imagen final
una cámara actual funciona exactamente
igual solo que en este caso el sensor es
un sensor digital
y esta es la clave que nos abre un mundo
casi infinito de posibilidades porque lo
digital como sabemos al final del día no
es más que una secuencia de unos y ceros
que podemos codificar decodificar y
prácticamente manipular a voluntad
la idea de usar computación y de
imágenes no es nueva esta es una imagen
de santorini en grecia tomada con un
teléfono móvil
sin embargo esta es una imagen que jamás
ha existido es una reconstrucción
computacional que se ha hecho en el
propio teléfono a partir de estas tres
imágenes y aquí estas tres imágenes han
sido cosidas para daros una imagen que
insisto jamás ha existido
bien con esta idea de computación vamos
entonces de nuevo a centrarnos en cómo
podemos ver lo invisible
aquí tenés una fotografía de un billete
una fotografía convencional con una
cámara normal
todos sabemos que si usamos una macro
podemos capturar muchos detalles
pequeños como por ejemplo la cabeza
diminuta del águila que veis ahí
sin embargo una foto es por definición
bidimensional
y perdemos todos los detalles de la
micro geometría del objeto que estamos
fotografiando esa textura que tiene el
billete cuando lo tocamos
os acordáis como hemos codificado luz en
el tiempo para transmitir un mensaje
basados en esta idea
hemos construido la siguiente micro
discoteca es una cúpula de este tamaño
más o menos con un montón de luces que
podemos encender y apagar a voluntad
creando infinidad de códigos
veis un agujero encima y se coloca una
cámara normal que apunta hacia abajo
colocamos nuestro billete de dólar
debajo
activamos una secuencia de códigos de
luz a la hora de hacer la fotografía
y el resultado es el siguiente como veis
hemos logrado capturar no sólo los
detalles que capturamos con una macro
sino esa sensación de tridimensional de
la fotografía únicamente aplicando un
código en la secuencia de iluminación de
la misma
esto puede ser útil por ejemplo para
crear nuevos mecanismos para detectar
billetes falsos
aquí tenemos otro ejemplo que
seguramente todos reconocemos todos
hemos hecho alguna vez fotografías tan
horribles como está fuera de foco donde
los detalles se han perdido
aparentemente para siempre
esto ocurre porque cuando una escena
está fuera de foco cada punto de la
escena se transforma en el llamado
círculo de confusión que es lo que
emborrona toda la imagen
y la observación fundamental es darse
cuenta que este círculo de confusión
está relacionado con la forma de la
apertura de la cámara que es circular
hemos diseñado un método donde
simplemente imprimes otro patrón
distinto sobre un plástico transparente
lo recortas lo coloca sobre la lente y
ahora si la escena está fuera de foco en
vez de un círculo de confusión
ese punto seguirá el patrón de tu nuevo
dibujo y con eso hacemos la fotografía y
pasamos de esto a esto donde podemos
descubrir detalles como el título del
libro
las letras que dan la textura del fondo
o incluso la cara de la muñeca
vamos a cambiar de tercio vamos a ver
ahora eventos ultra rápidos tan rápidos
que es difícil de ver a ojo desnudo este
tipo de vídeos están por internet son
muy populares seguro que los habéis
visto pero requieren cámaras
que sean capaces de capturar miles de
fotogramas por segundo
estas cámaras pueden llegar a costar
hasta 100 mil dólares
utilizando computación vamos a ser
capaces de capturar el mismo tipo de
eventos pero utilizando una cámara
convencional y lo que es más interesante
todavía una sola fotografía como ejemplo
la llama de este mejoro encendiéndose
esta es la única fotografía que
capturamos de todo el evento
pero si nos fijamos en esta zona vemos
que no es una fotografía convencional
vemos una serie unos patrones de blancos
y negros un código óptico que hemos
introducido con una máscara de manera un
poco similar a la idea anterior y
gracias a este patrón a este código que
introducimos al hacer insisto una sola
fotografía podemos reconstruir todo el
evento de la llama encendiéndose en
cámara lenta
bien
vamos a pasar a otro ejemplo el último
quizá mi favorito hace dos o tres años
trabajando en el mate
nos planteamos que otras escenas muy
rápidas serían difíciles de capturar
buscamos un desafío que existe en el
mundo que sea prácticamente imposible de
capturar de tan rápido que es incluso
con las mejores cámaras existentes
después de mucho pensar llegamos a la
solución obvia la luz
por toda la física que conocemos nada
puede ser más rápido que la luz a
trescientos mil kilómetros por segundo
la luz es lo más rápido que existe en el
universo
ahí teníamos el desafío interesante
podemos capturar luz en movimiento
no voy a entrar en detalles el proceso
fue largo pero voy a pasar a enseñaros
la
escena final
pensar que para capturar luz en
movimiento estamos un billón de
fotogramas por segundo
lo cual es mecánicamente imposible de
conseguir
necesitamos entonces apoyarnos de nuevo
en la computación
y este es nuestro resultado
lo que veis es un pequeño marcianito de
juguete de plástico colocado delante de
un espejo que sucede cuando damos la luz
esto lo experimentas todos los días
cuando vais al bani deis la luz que
sucede
vemos el muñeco y vemos su reflejo
y ocurre tan rápidamente que nuestro
cerebro registra los dos eventos como
simultáneos pero si pensamos lo que está
sucediendo al dar la luz los fotones
tienen que viajar de la fuente de luz al
juguete del juguete al espejo del espejo
a los ojos y a 300.000 kilómetros por
segundo nuestro cerebro lo detecta como
simultáneo pero no son eventos
simultáneos
entonces ahora vais a ver por primera
vez cómo se forma un reflejo de un
espejo
y lo vuelvo a poner se ilumina el
juguete no hay reflejo todavía aparece
poco a poco el reflejo porque los
fotones han tardado en llegar al espejo
bien hemos visto una serie de ejemplos
de cómo ver lo invisible a través de la
computación superar los límites de la
física en la mecánica a través de
computación pero no queremos pararnos
ahí queremos seguir pensando en desafíos
no a uno o dos años vistas sino a cinco
a diez a veinte años vista trabajar en
problemas que parezcan absurdamente
difíciles por empezar a trabajar en
ellos ya
actualmente estamos colaborando con nasa
en un proyecto de exploración de las
cuevas de la luna
la idea es que mandar un astronauta para
explorarlas es peligroso y caro mandar
un robot es caro con nuestra tecnología
de un billón de fotogramas por segundo
quizá pudiéramos bombardear las cuevas
de las lunas de fotones dejar que los
fotones reboten por las cuevas y lleguen
otra vez al sensor de la cámara y a esa
velocidad podemos preguntar
individualmente a cada fotón donde han
estado y que han visto y reconstruir la
información de todos para crear ese mapa
de la cola de la luna sin entrar jamás
en ella
en este proyecto es interesante no solo
por el desafío científico o por trabajar
con nasa en un proyecto de exploración
espacial para mí es particularmente
estimulante porque es un ejemplo de una
aplicación novedosa que nosotros jamás
imaginamos cuando diseñamos nuestra
cámara
y esto para mí refuerza el mensaje de la
necesidad de permanecer curiosos de
abordar problemas no porque sean
sencillos sino porque son difíciles de
volver a recuperar la pasión por la
ciencia por saber por descubrir esa
pasión puede estar en cualquier sitio
para mí vino desde chiquitito con los
libros de códigos y mensajes secretos
y aunque el presente es estimulante el
futuro lo es mucho más porque no sé qué
novela de ciencia ficción me va a
inspirar no sé si sacaremos más
información de la luz o si al final
lograremos tener éxito con nuestro
proyecto de cuevas lunares porque en
ciencia muchas veces lo más excitante es
lo que no puedes prever muchas gracias